this week on we love science we're
talking ass droid weight or my my
asteroid for sure this is we love
science
hey everybody welcome to wheel of
the interactive show where we answer
your questions about the universe and by
we I certainly don't mean me we have
with us the one the only your own
personal astrophysicist dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson Oh what's up Neil
Chuck how you doing thanks for asking
man I'm great uh where are you beaming
in from Vancouver British Columbia and
for geographically challenged Americans
that's Canada filming the last few days
of cosmos God you are all over the place
man would love to be you right now
not let's not get into your fantasy okay
all right it's time to talk asteroids
are you ready Neil
I'm ready Chuck spin that wheel Daniel
Ticknor wants to know what is the
easiest way to defend the Earth from
asteroids I didn't even know they were
trying to attack us what you want to do
is first find out that is headed our way
then as early as you possibly can slowly
deflected out of harm's way because if
the earlier you get it you don't have to
deflect it by very much and that angle
accumulates and gets wider and wider and
wider so that it completely misses earth
the later you do this the more
significant you have to deflect it so
that it does not hit Earth and it was
headed right at us you have to deflect
it the entire diameter of the earth just
to avoid collisions so the earlier the
better in all time in all cases so how
would you do that well one way is you
can like paint one side of the asteroid
jet black and that will absorb more
sunlight than the other side and when
that happens it radiates at a different
rate from one side to the other and that
difference in radiation rates has a
pressure that pushes it into a new orbit
but there's still issues at how much
spray paint you need for the kiss or
what what would you actually take out
there to accomplish this and these
asteroids are large the the ones we're
worried about a miles across okay and if
your European kilometers across but
that's a lot of spray paint so
what is another way to do it yes you can
send a spaceship out there and have it a
space probe and park it near the
asteroid so here's the asteroid and here
is the space probe just Park it there
now what's gonna happen is their gravity
is gonna want to attract them to one
another but you don't let that happen
you fire little retro rockets
so that pulls the the spaceship a little
farther away and then the asteroid falls
towards it and it's very steady but it
is in effect a gravitational tractor
beam it's like a gravitational tether
and that way you can measure how
effective it is and how long you should
do it and so that's clearly the best way
to protect Earth from asteroids so
blowing it up Armageddon style that's
not a good choice
no in America especially we're really
good at blowing stuff up but we're not
as good as no at knowing where the
pieces will land so you don't know what
effect exploding it will have after
you've blown it up so what's the saying
Ellis Bruce Willis is a proton wait if
the way I put it is if we are gonna blow
it up for whatever reason I'd send Bruce
Willis all right Neil it's time for
another question are you ready
spin the wheel Matthew Vincente Lee
betturtle wants to know this when
considering the asteroid belt where did
all the asteroids come from I'm
genuinely curious also if there were an
asteroid headed towards Earth how would
it be made known to the public okay now
so where'd the asteroids come from well
first let me say where they are most of
them are between the orbit of Mars and
Jupiter hundreds of thousands of them
and the craggy chunks of rock left over
from the formation of the solar system
and we think many of them tried to
become planets like planetesimals and
they that an end of the then the solar
system back then was basically a
shooting gallery and as they're trying
to become planets they get broken up
into bits and pieces so they're really
the vagabonds of the solar system so
what's an is the space garbage like
Pluto Chuck don't get me started a I'm
joking I'm joking okay how about the
second half of Matt's question how are
we gonna know that we're all gonna die
all the movies always show government's
detecting the asteroid with some special
telescopes and then keeping it a secret
excuse me you cannot keep the sky a
secret it is above all our heads and
there are countless thousands of amateur
astronomers with backyard telescopes
that look into the universe and find
these things and so you realize that
most comets up until recently most
comets were found by amateur astronomers
and asteroids too so now we have
specialized telescopes but they're
controlled by us not by the government
so yeah if we if we find one you're
gonna know the next day the next day
because that stuff will go public and
that everybody will find out at the same
time very likely via the internet and it
is no secret anybody can keep sorry no I
don't believe you
I've got a feeling they're not telling
anybody anything and then they're gonna
take that information and escape on
their own or maybe that's just what I
would do
I'm an awful person if we're gonna get
hit by an asteroid would you want to
know voting the poll on the screen right
now and see what everybody else did hey
man thanks for being here as always it's
my pleasure until next time this is
Chuck nice four we love science and keep
that ass
[Music]
you